[Music]
have you guys been keeping up with all
the rides that's been happening
i have yes protests what do you guys
think about there's like
a riots happening like protests god damn
it
protests happening in like 12 major
cities all over the us man this is our
rodney king like our yeah it's crazy
yeah so if you guys don't know the riots
are happening because of the death of
george floyd
um so there are people going around
writing protesting they started looting
and uh there's obviously a lot of things
that happening when the
looters come out but the cairns still
have to meet their quotas are still
carrying it up they're karen's are karen
karen pd
i feel sorry for all the karen's there
aren't that aren't karen like out it's a
nice name
they've dragged in there yeah but i have
a couple of karen friends yeah
but uh yeah so they've been going out
and trying to stop the looters and
there's
one specific video from the looting and
the writing where
a woman in a wheelchair tried to stop
the looters by
a karen in a wheelchair a karen in a
wheelchair next level karen yeah
yeah i don't know is that advance or
because you kind of feel bad for her
professor k professor
wait so how how did she try to stop him
so
everyone was trying to rush into the
target right so she tried to barricade
the doors
with her wheelchair and then with a
knife and start swinging at people
yeah so she tried to kill people for
that's
that's a murderer her story she doesn't
work for them not feeling
affiliate just trying to do her civil
duty of stuff what did she think would
happen by doing that
everyone's gonna be like yes karen i'm
so sorry
yeah i guess in her mind mostly he's a
vigilante yeah
yeah i feel bad i feel bad for her
because like if any of you guys have
been in high school you've seen like a
rumble
teachers get trampled you know like
people are in that wild state of mind
they're not gonna listen to anybody but
those are people that are
supposed to stop true this is just like
when things happen like this you should
not well at least from what i've learned
in a lot of different things you don't
put yourself
in a situation where other people are
supposed to stop it especially
if you're a lady in a wheelchair with a
knife yeah and also who the [ __ ] can't
just target yeah
what is this what is her like target
will be okay what is her duty
national treasure that's what insurance
is for so there's two videos it's not a
mom and pop shop you know
the first video is of the actual
incident um and then if you guys look
closely you guys can see like her swing
something around which they
say it was a knife and then the second
video is her talking to
some reporter or something basically
saying like they went crazy they started
attacking me and she was trying to play
a victim
oh my god they put a fire extinguisher
on it
i was like it's like a [ __ ]
club but the fog machine just went off
you were peacefully protesting
shady dude such a victim
i got punched in the head several times
i got grabbed you're trying to kill
people
i got based
she literally had a knife and she was
sticking people with it yeah yeah so i
think one guy actually got hit with it
i'm surprised she didn't die
dude because yeah that is dangerous just
getting hit with a fire signature is
pretty cause then like
if you're gonna jump into something like
that especially at
that in terms of this is all racially
motivated or like the the looting and
stuff like that came from a hate crime
to be a white woman trying to stop
people late story about work
and people come and just [ __ ] pull
you out of the car and just start
stomping on your ass
i mean that's what could have happened
yeah but
she got away she got away dude i
remember like there was a uh
during the rodney king uh riots right
there was a white truck driver that made
the wrong turn
yeah it was a saddest [ __ ] they had
so much like anger at the time they
grabbed anybody that was white
so they stopped the truck they pulled
them out and they basically like pretty
much
beat them half to death oh i remember
that too oh i only remember that because
they
jim carrey like living kelly they did
like a bit about it
oh my god so it was rodney king and jim
carrey as that white truck driver
it was so yo this could never be done
nowadays but it was jim carrey as the
white truck driver
and he was like and he's all crossed out
he's like yeah i just took a wrong turn
and
i don't know what happened i just uh i
think i remember that
and then he's like could everybody just
get along
stuff like that like if that's like that
would actually happen just so wrong
that's pretty sad but with the instant
like this like she's asking for it yeah
watching it because we all kind of laugh
you feel bad for laughing or
i don't feel bad at all man i mean like
well at the end of the day i feel like
just as a human it's sad to watch
any of that crazy ass chaos but at the
same time i think it's
kind of funny watching someone get fire
extinguished
and that's a pretty small thing for
trying to stab you that's true
like you don't go into a crowd of angry
people put on a fighting stance and for
her in her case it's a [ __ ]
knife and and expect nothing to happen
to you you know
especially when it's like for what it's
target
like who cares you know but it is funny
because she's like it's almost like
she's playing like rock paper scissors
did you hold the knife
[Laughter]
[ __ ] i didn't know i had this fourth
option
so i saw this video this morning um man
i should have just prepped it for this
because it just popped in my head but
there's some weird [ __ ] going on right
so they caught this guy
on camera and he had a gas mask on he
had an umbrella on he had a hoodie on
yeah and he had a hammer and he was
going up to the glass
uh autozone uh windows and he was
smashing it like this
right and a protester he was holding a
pizza
and he was coming up to him a black dude
right and then he was just like stop
stop
right and then the guy he turns around
it's a white dude
and then he doesn't want to be seen on
camera he's closing it and he's smashing
more windows and he calmly walks away
and the other guy's like you want to
fight bro
you want to fight hold my blood and then
they were going to get down
and they were like he's a cop he's a cop
and so right now they haven't
confirmed it a hundred percent but
people that
might know who he is they put a picture
next to him yeah so it's not 100
confirmed yet but
the guy that that they put a picture up
of he's a detective yeah
so they're saying that like to make this
movement
even more [ __ ] up and so that the the
national guard could come in and
whatever
the government is allowing uh
you know guys within the department to
come out and destroy
property and make and then there was a
bunch of guys that came out with pallets
right
all dressed in black none of them black
all white guys right and they started
lighting [ __ ] on fire
that's what i'm more scared of is like
the [ __ ] be behind it
yeah it's like the purge yeah when the
purge they they weren't getting enough
violence and
if you guys watched the movie like not a
lot of violence was happening they
wanted the people in the
inner city like those bad communities to
kill each other more but they weren't so
they had their people
the white people or just people in the
government come out and start killing so
they add to the numbers or start like
inciting more violence and
it's like that's what the government
does or like if they're trying to get
like a
something across like that so like
that's the crazy [ __ ] right because
we're
now with everyone having cameras like
we're seeing it firsthand we heard about
it but now we're catching [ __ ] doing
this [ __ ] because he definitely looks
like he stands out i saw the
video clip too right he has like a
[ __ ] his gas mask is some like
real [ __ ] yeah it's like military grade
yeah
like his ex-wife came out and was like
uh the reason why she could recognize
him was was like that was a very
specific gas mask and he also wore like
gloves that were hers or like he knew
and then she sent that to like
i think like one of her his old friends
was like
no that's that's him like that's
specific so so that's
who outed him because there was a photo
next to it dude that's [ __ ]
nuts are they looking for this guy then
is he it's all being all blasted
it's being blasted it's like unless
people continue to push for it it could
just get
let go the national guard is in
minneapolis already though
like they already mobilized that so it's
getting crazy over there
and then on the 110 or 101 there's like
chp cars getting
um bashed in oh yeah it's just crazy
that like
if again like with the same thing that
happened to the other guy ahmed
uh abed right um arbury um
if it wasn't for social media i don't
think it would if the people didn't
start rioting and looting so it's like
sometimes it's kind of saying like
it's bad elute but like i think the the
cop would have been
completely fine if nothing happened yeah
i think society's just
reacting to how sick they are and they
they feel helpless so now they're gonna
do
the thing that you know we can't be a
civil society and if our system doesn't
work then we're gonna result to being
um just raged out creatures right yeah
and they're like
be civil and it's like well the civil uh
laws aren't working
so we're not gonna be civil we're gonna
be animal and we're going to raise a
raise some [ __ ] hell and it's also
during this time don't you think it's
odd it's like during this time where
we're all stuck at home we're all in
quarantine we're all powerless we're all
like
the working class is powerless you know
yeah it seems like
there's a lot of intersecting [ __ ]
things
that are fueling the fire yeah it feels
weird to be like yeah
like [ __ ] you know loot burn [ __ ]
down but like you know
it gets to a point where people get so
frustrated with
not seeing any results right like how
many times can you [ __ ] retweet or
like uh make a sign before it's like yo
this isn't doing [ __ ]
i need to show them like hey bro like
i'm fed up with this you know
true like when you get in that argument
with your girlfriend it's like you can
only yell each other like for so long
before you need to like
punch a wall yeah i steal her tv and go
in the room and take her tv out yeah
just taking your tv light her little
please you say go in her room
[Laughter]
well this is something that's been kind
of suspected during the occupy
movement remember when there were mad
protests happening in
all major cities right so one conspiracy
was that
the police force or the government was
using tactics
of using uh outside military
security groups such as blackwater or
whatever i don't think they exist now i
think they changed their name but
these guys were hired to come in and
discredit protests
uh as violent so it gives reason for the
police to come in and use lethal force
or
tear gas or whatever because most of
these movements they're just marches and
and protests right but then you guys
you know you see these guys are just
smashing up windows and start doing this
thing and maybe
like hired people that yeah black lives
matter movement
that aren't and do you know other
conspiracy with like george soros being
the head of
that behind everything what's that
well that it's it's like that where like
basically there's black lives matter
which are
people that are they're trying to start
a good movement right but then it's like
intercepted with so then the violence
happens from the people that uh
they attribute to the black and they use
the same hashtags they do that we're for
black lives matter but they're violent
and they do all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
so that the police can come in or they
can escalate it to
this extra it makes like a group that's
like for crime
and like yeah yeah and it's further
credits and it further divides
everyone racially and it's yeah it's so
interesting because i don't know
how much of that is true but it's it's
very
at this time especially with the world
it's like some things that we always
thought were just conspiracy or like
coming out it's like stuff that we would
never see or think would happen
especially in our time
yeah it's like happening and like during
a pandemic it's like
i already was scared of people rioting
because of losing their jobs and like
being in a pandemic so those people with
all the guns that were
right in front of the cops pushing the
cops spitting on the cops didn't do
anything because
like white people were like oh that i
think that was like one of the big
debates was like showing the discrepancy
of like
people protesting before the rioting and
stuff happened but getting hit with uh
maze cans or um or tier tear gas cans
compared to all the people that showed
up in like full military gear just
standing up to the cops
you mean the one that uh i think it was
in oklahoma or something like that i
think it even happened uh
people were walking around with military
gear in like the oc and they were having
like that they're standing up to the the
cops but because they were white
uh the argument is the cops didn't shoot
him on site and all this stuff oh
that's their american right to protest
like that i didn't get
like do you see how many cops were in
front of like the murderer yeah 75 cops
yeah that was insane like that guy's
there's something fishy that doesn't
seem like a normal pop
right 75 cops in front of the guy that
kneeled on his neck
yes his house what the hell
and he wasn't even arrested or anything
and well now he's been arrested i just
got a notification that he was
arrested yeah i also read on twitter
that he was arrested in florida
yeah so he fled he has a history of this
[ __ ]
so like i feel like when all the cops
were outside his house they knew he had
bounced already and it was all like a
[ __ ] diversion so he could get out
yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah so then uh he shot someone
else um
he killed a native american man what um
yeah a few years ago he
shot he broke into some guy's house beat
him with a gun and then shot him in the
stomach and that guy came out on the
news like recently for real
yeah so you have a history of like very
violent like
violent other races yeah the white dude
and the asian dude and that's in the
george floyd video he has a history too
with like violence and stuff and he's
been comple
he has complaints on his uh uh history
uh so like they both have problems
i think he has 12 complaints 12
complaints i recently saw
like a comparison right so there's a
there's a black guy
uh from the same department and his
stray bullet
accidentally shot like a white woman and
she died he's got 12 and a half years
sentenced as a police officer right and
the you know they're saying like would
would the same
thing happen to this guy the blue veil
doesn't even protect
all of the blue yeah it doesn't maybe it
doesn't you know because that other guy
got
sentenced to 12 and a half years oh bro
i also saw on twitter that
they did the autopsy of um of george
floyd right
and they said they did not detect
anything actually choked him they said
it was his pre-existing medical
conditions
and who did the who did the autopsy
right the police department
i don't know either way like what
ignited those pre-existing conditions
like
and either way that treatment is not
constitutional
like that's not there's all these other
people coming out showing them like
being
it's funny because it's like their kids
putting their knee on their on their
neck
and being like look i'm fine oh god are
you serious
who is fighting for this guy that
doesn't make any sense
you